This is a. She's a few years old.
One night I got rather friendly with you know just very very very we would meet every night just so I did all the
really cold calling for a hotel called the National this is a prison reserve and that was the life they are with us.
I think for supplies
and I would like for them to garrison the city was right there for the rest of the game so we got very good.
There was certainly it was like there's a degree there when you're ready when you hear little
or nothing at all that for a little more special mission. Yes they sure will be there for years here obviously.
Oh but there will likely make the rounds on a Friday night.
Mainly out of that out this year and a very good one of the process.
The trouble with going without a year of our early years was before that you know there will be guys like here.
Yes and I don't know whether they're going to get sixty. But it was a balance. Yes yes.
Obviously they're quite rich occasion right for the manager
and there's really days I'm sitting there I used to do it all my life I think people are just crazy.
They just will go if you're real sure you get House is going to turn your head back
and you're kind of dazed you're right now let's have a little bit of news for you over here just to which one can reach
their goal or in the foyer or the luxury.
This was all in the toilets Yes and sometimes you guys don't often use that you're in the same line as you
and that sort of Hawker around the back like the way you sat or you really you just get it.
It's a rather isolated actually one spot of the where people of the men are worrying here with us where there was
result news something to die here used to be a fire her. I still get it.
And yes they do the heavy programs lasting a bit of a null reacquire around re-arrest the state gives you a list
and you get your share just blew it was a book called the leader. It was a joy to know you're here.
She told me right here where I see you haven't been real. It was.
Yes I think it was years ahead of me yeah that's right. You sort of got to be there.
While I was down in the little chilly New York and the roads around the world.
I don't know where I was I was having a theory let's imagine. Let's just say well it really.
Let's see you there actually are living journalists.
A really rough day here a year like cyclists did here first year of their right to have a look at your options.
While the first letter to the point is women do it all right. It's just you're right.
I mean women had the same sort of experience as I said Really.
But both started work here because of the way right now well over your daughter says
and he resists she's got a lot of things she really very good one called a chariot here. Well three in the war.
Very true. You know.
Well you know the psychologically difficult right here because I don't believe the life really was that
when I was in my early. I really doubt it was sort of like I was just here that we were there for that.
We always go back for such a good run.
Just what you want to do is a sure thing you can't lose your chorus boy boy old girl. The least little of course boys.
Of course Boy I mean this is a rather coarse boys who are good but here is the chorus.
I didn't think about because I really didn't have much of a scene or dancing is brutal or The very quickly
and he was hoping to become the last person you know but he was a he used to love your wife here as a window person
and he hats princes for older you probably come over.
Hopefully Michael floral hats design tires for recreates or better their outfits and they can be here for the right.
Task or strong you must be hard to go all the extra time.
OK Yes well there it was my grandchild was the children's author but they were suppressed.
Yet there was a right never wrong a great certainly won't get it right the Riddick got it right with it because they
are extremely amusing very quickly
and they're a shock to your columns for sure because they will say well he was always there was new really real.
Well it was fun to say progress not really use it but he would never do about science.
If you didn't hear it was well I didn't hear it for three or youngster you know I was a youngster in the street kid
and he measured the road has never had much money there not a rigid rule.
Nary had much money in those days and he didn't like he did like thirty year old girl.
So he planted all over the place here a race.
We got out of here and he changed all that for every tree you see and then he invited the land.
He used to call North after they didn't like it.
No theory because I think you just don't want to hear that you're cut it off which he had done everything like title of
the radio everything so that business is a relay race
and I didn't get struck in the day I didn't have a reason coming and I didn't say right. Please you to do that.
Get away with us now that I'm like you but you never read Iris.
But there you might say she didn't have very right here at the Sunday night was nice to meet a friend of mine down
there with me before. All right. Hotel hall then boy.
Tell me just a little bit more about we would have to cram into the city close to six we would go from we get up to the
route so we didn't pay anything you know later the failures and the child does not come back to you as you see it
and then we walk along the coast to the Capitol.
We went into the California
and you're just expose you get a couple of weeks ago that I have a copy of it's maybe numerals Cleary But we said the
cup of coffee and Joe the waitress and giving us a refill retreated
and that will take us right through to all of our old law from from all that well you know that.
Was I mean then you would drift from table to table you say oh excuse me I did this for my kids every time you trade
your way through all the tables
and you drop your friend there they say there for a while then you see somebody else for the overall a good review was
a real social life you ran from table to table that you contact eventually if your original table then at about ten
o'clock at night believe that we would walk along down William Street again walking down the side of the top.
But being recklessly raised over the heads for nearly two cups of coffee.
We would start the fish shop right sticks a vision everybody knows was really Street and across to we knew we ha ha ha.
And I was six and that was there that I did that week after week after week.
I thought it was mild the sort that was living up to the very you know they're there on the radio runs and.
Running from your career
but what about this time you were the one Mexico where to lay everything you're doing your job that he did he was going
in for he was the one who did it he was a great deal because he was the one do kind of yeah yeah I'm what it was all
the rest of it. Oh while we are on the right road well just around about this time I hear folks.
I just carried you in Sydney. The first time while we're here and I said to this friend.
There's no one I should make this and we have no real way of working here. So he said I wish you could tell.
So I said How are you a story just in the oriental way up today but it was just me until it drops.
Yes but next time and Beryl recently Canberra or it was up the Orient and he came out to set up a jury.
He said to get a number two very thoughtful jury has Mr Garrick and the other of my purse.
So you every bit as if to put this list of the crew here
and I was just to get ready because all of that actually hear what he was about six eight hours was there.
Always a letter. Yes but you know very happy.
I mean I was pretty he was there was debris to get a record there's a buring hung classic was you get your good really
really having a suit or a rest and he was over there were probably. Well I was very caring person.
This was a couple people. No one. Yeah yeah yeah I know you say gay people disagree with you.
This is a shame you need to be family. The right people with any moral issues so to say people aren't around for a bit.
I got a bit worried about summer when you discuss it with your friends I mean you're looking at you
and as you might actually be very good go out there while I'm sitting right there was a little bit little bit so you
hear the truth.
I mean yeah yeah yeah I mean what do you know you hear a guy like that where people hear through this man
but I also think the fans are you a lot of the way that I fly while they're already. Oh yeah.
You told me that they would get up in here
and they would make us a lot of people were just trying to be sort of physical there right here there.
After he left my dream
and part of his US business to this company was much more I just spent a lot of time his company
and I was always full of some left with very little to do and I thought.
I know now about the guys on who knows what drives one with her own life and I stood on the corner.
Well it was because school knew that that was very very nice to stand because that was the most obvious place to stand
where it was.
I know because Russell has slid very long young very young so I was originally you know I don't even know who he did he
says you know myself and he sang lead gets the record
and I very carefully actually read that because he's from looking my way
and I'm very very he went up to it was a whole other target area but I did
and he said oh how he said I was afraid my house was dark and the sight of it had a little higher
and higher come out from Congressman miles driven see her I said well you know if you look at all.
Dolly that he's sort of very already located.
You never really know our youngest son just where he should be and he was.
What should I know is how to handle a case about short and.
A list goes on forever and you missed the foreign tourist he was in another prison like my dad and half life over.
I guess life.
I picked up a bit of rock tried to just come out of his
and what he's done for the night of the best I was that he was a was at his house the best was great and him
and began chatting to me
and then eventually this very seedy Carrie came along with all that much of the world outside Tracy
and I'll say this is my story and I'll resign Rouse rather than tell you that I was around
and we went on to work with mystery man
and players that were rough like it was the latest example there's not a lot of this bone was Joe exactly the first
glance that once saw the picture of the camp.
Oh yes I'm sure and I'm sure she was still there but that was my first introduction to do anything right here
and your magic was right around the forty five sixty three area here. I don't know of another friend.
I mean he didn't cite where would I let me run off quite a bit like it was with Ralph actually
but I left like well the night.
Just brought along with me to carry the bags I love to run right through your place here here here.
The other place was a new restaurant that was right in the right players the other players parties together.
Did you know her well your very soul she talked about why she was just like you really really you do you know you
really really really really really come this year. Roses there she was like that's like a year old just like shopping.
Wasn't it. Feeling like oh late late night shopping shopping at Star Wars when you're exactly right. Probably not yet.
And yeah never said a morning your good reason to worry your sure sure.
Trouble you eat hair right there actually right here got this right here.
So he writes what he writes and says shit he or she cannot go on result she got a lawyer skewed or a really long one.
Yes look it up for a living off course it will help Eastern European countries. Here's a story here.
That was really fun. This is because it was a guy you will. I think it must be she's a bit like life as in the rest.
You know it's obvious you know the I guess a restaurant.
You know how to shoot the gastro try restaurants with the restaurant
and say how do you know it's not the restaurant is going to be quite so good but natural didn't change it.
She sighed because I assumed it was. If you will like the regime. Life is good because people are going to get a lot.
She says there's a visiting a lot of people here that shows up with so that's probably going to just lose a shoe size
was coming out.
It was kind and it with me she said that it took a good French restaurant
but I mean you know French really did she really for all of that said religion gravity is true
and she had a very strong personality and that even though I think Christ.
Yes we get like he was selling the last series she shares in the hours of your French restaurant
and the price was a lot of very well she got very long. Yeah yeah but he was really in there once.
Yes with the gentleman that I was with and if it was so you get there and live up to the rent that the rent.
Here is are probably very sharp to the regulars of course the real world just recently which was a street market street
out to keep the street three hundred was probably the most. So far as it was measured.
The regular proper satellite system we saw that night dances they used to be for you know rooms which was the sort of
well looking back pretty boy. Yeah it was just like a rise here by years old.
Really it was like a very serious just off the wall.
Here you know about you know like Shallow Hal sounds very softly
and nothing exotic nothing it was really very right at the restaurant.
We record here there were very little you know a lot of it was a little bit. I mean what was my son.
Yes right there was mayday call as such or I'm sorry I mean it was just like a little restaurant.
It was a time that matter. Was it you or it was better because it was just tables and chairs very orderly.
But most places were in those days but it was in there as I was in the basement of the G. and G.
So didn't draw walls on the ceiling were probably good because again if they are using they are safely buried which we
are you know you really are in a car and our car people are looking out here and I rather fancy the tables
and chairs the tables are right there with the bright light which was a bit because the headlights didn't reasonably
high sitting up very light because it was based not only cantilever slightly probably are.
There's nothing structurally it was all right good here I read the painting the paint you know the interior painting
dominated by the piano player one corner where you will eventually see the Man Who are you sure she said I felt like
something big like we all are
and really only an opera singers a lot of there's a piano to the shop I always raise a baby right here.
So you know you noticed here is not unusual at all for a piano to be a quarter of the room so you're not there yet you
with your heart. That's just your heart or develop nuclear you never did mention love to you.
I didn't think it was a resident Rosalynn nor your Sarah and all the writers and people like that she was really here.
She was there so it was more just it was more than just hear hear us.
We're going to hear a lot more is expected in the it was like there were two of it here.
I did a recent series of little old black and white and theatrical books for you.
Yeah it was all the more the right drugs with Israel rushes to be used to draw you out because there's a theory around
right now you want to hold it like don't do use husband had started the story he had with generic usually not with you
if you know your problems lie then you write this love all.
Just the meals very great for everybody so just me
and you get nothing for about you get coffee with US style because of the DOT say it was more of all right.
It was a very serious issue was the result was we all here really really really had the right.
I mean the kind with the crash of Air.
I was trying to find out about you and you just very sure what you want to do and I love her with you know your
and your letter gram Good gracious and there's some high value and she was apparently way
or did you just say Oh a lot of really good dancers. There used to work on the Wilson's point station.
This would be just sort of through you know run by a man called the rich for fools rich family you know this is the
really nobody can gauge where this should man up and you know
and really hungry Lester you want to marry I want is the way to live.
I guess that's just something you read through this really was younger
but they were you know there is no life from here it is just on the north shore station and you.
Well you didn't like sharks of mission challenging mission before their mission.
Well I think growing drug drug here with growth would all be better off.
Let the last apartment to somebody and that somebody must love source the people.
It's you that's that big computer person three years ago I run sure you used to go out stairs to hear of the accident.
Oh yeah pastoralist Well it was really quite a little over an hour ago long room with a very familiar lover's maze
dance regularly just pretty good because you could go you can dance.
You know man off the wall or you really do and I love you.
Yes the floor go through the always play at dances
and you wear jewelry three days around the piano grounds a couple of ice shelves full of years and years
and well you know the Sundance thing here yesterday right here the most likely they used to be there's every day's have
three street done that was done desk quite popular quite a number of the little coffee drinkers old out of a really
strong nice cheap groceries for their head around as they are normally you would really like that.
If you are right right there.
It's all hands on through to the plant world yours there and here you dance with that for ya.
Life is because your life you dance for my dear girl that you wish she she would do it is that she is ready that's
really really the way fascinating because I know this year I know my risk to go dance or get off with a big win
and that was the drag bit of track there I remember very few on the road. I learned there's a very old man.
There he vested in me here with the black hair because
and I remember he sang resolutely to the set with the folds of my hand very heavy bag
or shawl over this whole Gulf of Pinched of the West Coasters of the oval black sort of dress
and had his that's true yeah true that was all yeah yeah piano player. Get up and go on.
Oh that really is your life
and this is the course to figure out we're right around allowed to dance for all remember this is utterly without
saying one of those maybe a bit lighter of course was over the period with the sun would she say to him for do you
think you can do as you well know well. Oh fuck. Somebody quite clearly but don't you love it.
Rub it in the hole about the fish in the middle of this he said well I was having issues.
I'm sure it's very good for their grief. Oh it was thirty dollars.
Oh I have your prayers pretty good because they said he sell it without really having a good feeling.
There's nothing was ever going up or fluff. But he said very clearly there was something to shift in my life.
Oh yeah probably. You can hardly hear it but it was surprising really he was going to have more people got to know me.
Yes he just got a particular Friday night it was for the house he was telling you the address to give you any right to
say has dissolved in the not the least you know yet. One of those anyway. You must run down really really.
And of course you can go like hell yes God I try to go over something really quickly to people on the course of this it
was so strong I just read a strong western suburbs and that's right.
Less of those little resort suburbs or just being across history rather like places where people are there
and oh yes to go around and very all over your flat tire.
The place where you just like you just want to hear because I'm really upset because your station three he was a very
well always straight to do very well yes I get the recurring answer yourself once I hear the Rex or the car.
Yes I hear. Yeah we genuinely thought you had a child.
Well you know it was then our station yesterday across used to every Sunday night.
Mind you this was getting really really really good role.
This is the night he used to regularly every Sunday
and I still live at his flat in a place just off the flat was in the Victoria Street I'll say Fredricka the regulars
from the right. He regularly every Sunday night. You knew you could go to like you get.
Are you going to places that we brought you.
Goodbye and he said he was my mom was out there was absolutely legal what he had us was a very devoted to do it.
Oh yeah well you do what you like but usually it's right there.
Yeah I think you'd agree especially if you get this yes he got you.
But if you like trying not as I know you have to get their agenda read you can't people like me here.
SILAS You get your reasons you get a good draw where you get to see what sells funny in those days was only worth.
You know it was very early in the wall all over the period over the every day and you get a yes
or is America's America not yet you the Americans
and yet now our this is exactly where you have to give a little you know with all the sixty's OK let's hear like he was
the first like sixty six. Here here.
This is very gracious like the method he used to work here he said Oh she's cancer of his mother with cancer of chance
might you know always remember like a telegram the frost Buchanan received he had other his
or his dressing room nearest be at the Telegraph said the Duchess.
She says cameras are out to get them that he didn't really notice this reply goes right that I have it is basically
where it was said by some that are just she says cancer out to get Iraq
and yet their prayers are being investigated further they say can't just park your car hit them.
How are you gonna be good with both hands. Larry. Can this club verify it.
OK but who do most of the oh yes those are your eyes are very good.
Yes they were provoked the while the working class working class was used to write here. Oh yes.
Are you sure you want Koresh so I had to do that because the other words he said was Where where where where oh where
is issues where on the ground of the right to free office for religion which she was used a lot of visitors get
sexually. It was all about G.B.H.
Was not the expression to be he actually tried to get the actual idea to be his brain
and so your people would last for that matter that's why his four sons have people walking on T.V.
and You know this is how we get a picture or a square mile square or a stand up that is that the worst thing
when there are sand all the careful of that just send out of ships not under a ship not to be a serious threat she said
she'd send you out she was dangerous.
This was a real right he's right on the right here before there was another big co-inventor Oh yes
but you'd say well this was where the young man on the base because all our own family like all of it not individual
will sit in the British T.V. Show movies and he's serious.
Here must be MORNING EDITION for a few big cities of the since the OP is the obviously the office of straight rugby
league here. My. Oh you do you mean you were yes you're equals which is if he was already there.
Drugs are only here where young new phrases such as the others in this area this gets years
or I really struggled along about I was pretty busy or something else
and it wasn't his fault that someone goes I would rather stay here a lot to help you a little more running along with
the big bucks here.
I mean you know you got my place their house or a street their registry was there the long run tells registry.
I don't know when that same letter but right next was. You know you're hauling occupied all this stuff right here.
That was sort of it was really his books are I think this is from this is fish around here
and you're just along the good of my head was along but it was a very handsome bar very small amount of old.
Yes mother of lowering a mole walling it was actually official I was no longer Well because I didn't have a lesson here
over all the old people place for seven I think it did yesterday this area right in the elderly
and you'll actually get a little bit far away
but that's yes he's slightly right in the wrong that you know a lot of walls you're really not nothing
or no I don't have the alley bending the wires to the nut and it over.
It's really good thing that happened to the physical you like.
He says she was going to cheat and cause somebody like Christmas table here's a guy that does exist
and on the footpath between From about him. I'll say something. Joe how six books said I was right.
Middle wrong restroom just outside waiting the last desperation to stand around her things on my side.
Oh I love her and quite often my knowing that I wasn't but I thought of all the terrible
but that's all I had a subject that I had out here on it's own Make see This Is Your Life.
Do you know how to go about it and you know it doesn't bite as much if you like I just get a refund for stuff.
Hear hear. Yes but I could never get over it all over the heavenly fire. It really was.
I was never yes I was never Yeah for love. There was this week with us right here.
You know I had my success in cutting the great picture already read literally the rhythm of the night he said you know
it's really fifty six. You know you'll have your list with the you know who knows what Justice.
It must have been a whole period with all of this other stuff.
No he said he said the regular edition I'll show you another place where we'll run here that does this
but I know I didn't know that you remember this is a studio also happens all the years of a man called Joe home away.
It was an office used to live there with his sister just so he stood there in the last years every day he regularly
getting your son that he'd rather we got that shot was good with the childish games like it was nothing over a lot
richer and there you wait long. There are girls in there was it.
Yeah I hear this is that they were always there and I like to go but you're always you're here at home.
People like people who are in here which is the concert to go show you the success and your role here more
or less continuously from about the end of the war the Kiwis just have been for about six weeks to come here
and know for a year it was a mild concert of the singles part from from the Second World War to a war
and intercourse was about drag their camp with.
Yes just war at the start of the show you're in there years and that's another person.
Johnny Hunter who has who is from here is a big star over here looking very pretty good beautiful looking
and very good actress actor but I feel like he's still raw.
He's working for the house
or Johnny hundreds somebody really comes out because I think he's above the law in the last little bit.
He was a little one and we all the girls would come back and he was not there a little love like for about three.
Through years old. President Bush. Well we had to get the business this week and he you feel you know you hear clues.
Well you're right you're matching I mean yes but I was serving.
I was like he was character
but I think like a lot of people thought Bill was more was more the sort of pantomime diary type of big business really
was you know your morals.
Show on Comedy of the Johnny Hunter was the real pretty glamorous he stands on point really about this rather life with
very well that's real the house still living on the whole Well I was thinking Lord of all that he does not hold up
rough John Christie he used to with Ross Jarrett years ago.
It's nice to see it on a mission that he was because he was there with us.
There will be in the ten years following the end of the war because that was their hearing myself I think that's a
charge quite a big way because they voted to enjoy whatever it. They were good for the early years of this.
It was just that they can become really really natural role models.
If your life really good were the only success he would just give you just very rarely see you call
or you would say living like you always this life is a life.
They are very coarse or stuff they run is doing stuff here
and there is a lot of writing poetry with that for all the girls all the right would have their rights for I say who
else was in his life much. We were told he would never feel just it was for the girl and also his court cases so sure.
Barbara Starr Norris charges something like this year around here if you go for your love life
and they're getting the right you know the worst serial that's what characters around that is a very good person.
You know this is why I really like the man but he's doing it with me and still a very good actress.
Let's get straight drunk you remember there's a character around here it just.
Like I just like a price to hear about it.
Finally got me all these years just like players because that's really doc's here here and there's the Duchess.
There's the Duchess the moment where I really pointed out to me I never met my terrible bass player just for the chair
but he must've been a bit sorry. Right. There's a you that's right that's right. They are right.
Little minor celebrity.
Right right before you get a load you get out of all this you know there and do us a little bit younger. We'll be much.
Oh yeah it's a little afraid. All right Larry said it's only like four years and then you sort of like a wish.
Because if it was all set up with Black Monday.
I think are there because I said it was like she knew this already
but it's in those days it was much better various it was a good thing that you didn't like the same people all the
weird how they should actually live the whole run that won't drag shows like they do the right thing.
The jewel box for the first time again very well if you look through the general public whether California where
or what you wish you good night. Rubbish. They're right.
Yes that's really the out there don't you want your boss is one of those places where you wait to see a drag.
Oh well it's a great great hall Nance really.
Under drag things like strip a lesser You know full that you'd have dragged before.
You had people living here is you have this fantastic hole in the sea wall that resort to either this
or a little liaison with more circus type was.
They really went through the circus with Russ just sort of just before the song you're left with all the duplicity
and he was a solo act and everywhere very little kind why don't you just read the news reviews
and with no great profits or jockstraps up for your fellows. That's all right.
But up until they're done before
but it was a single moment so young to old guys like you all you didn't get dragged mess.
It's a big golden era of this sort of transvestite types that have bristled at the resort you put in here.
I did it with three or four story just to look at here very British humor with a new little jokes life.
Well you know very little rock star. Drug like nobody would be in the middle fifty's.
Well I think the like very like what you would do well on life. Oh my God love you. Those kind of.
Oh yes a lot of us yelling was the river. I thought the eggs at the cinema this hospital done right it was hard.
Yet with the similar price
and I thought you got it through the cinema hall Helstar room door a big room with people like that really cold.
First piracy drag this out so I think I remember
when I was really really well we are living across that here that they are signs that said Of course you know where the
truck was you know you guys about two
or three years old this year so I suppose my life was fine unless you're absolutely right.
That's because the old world. There was also is there a horse. I hope you like but there is a book about young people.
They say family you say you knew this car or steal or Michael Vick. They're all good for nothing.
A lot of really they really don't like the jargon that a lot yet raising here here.
Plus appears to be a lot easier
or whatever it was right there something that people here at the wall of silence just actually were just refused to be
OK love you love me love because you know what this is saying get him out there. Right. Famous case it was some man.
It was right.
Well you know I mean it was something like all three of him carrying something they do in that case with a young chap
and you can hear that again that was about you. Yes yes yes oh yes the first draft was.
Yes a little that was given tremendous coverage and with that.